it seems like a lot of the film's you
cover or more studio films but I'm sure
you love indie films yeah why do you
think the mainstream is so resistant to
indie films I mean is it because there's
not names talent in them the the endings
are unclear or sometimes depressing why
do you think that the mainstream well I
think I think mainstream movie goers are
obviously consumed by and borderline
obsessed with celebrity and celebrity
culture as somebody who's worked at you
know different outlets over the years
that have covered celebrity lifestyle I
see that first hit so it's hard
sometimes maybe for an audience to find
a movie that doesn't have a recognizable
face or doesn't have a name that they
trust or know and sometimes nowadays
really comes down to availability I mean
look at this weekend you've got that's
my boy and rock of ages to big studio
films that are coming out and about
3,000 theaters they even film like your
sister's sister that plated all the
festivals Toronto Sun dins Tribeca with
a well-known actress emily blunt and
rosemarie dewitt it was on Mad Men and
she's no no Rachel Getting Married an
indeed that crossed over a little bit
that movies coming out on 13 screens
this weekend how can people go and see
it they came it so they might read about
it or they might see my interview with
Emily on our show but it's tough for
them to see it while Rock of Ages they
can't turn without seeing it so I think
availability is a big reason why now
thanks to video on demand and netflix
and things coming out on DVD faster
after their their being released in
theaters I think indie films are finding
their audience it just takes a little
longer the immediacy it is not the same
obviously as a studio process just
because of simply availability on some
level
you